how fun was the live show
that was pretty fun that was really it
was so fun I was like hi the next day
Pete and Liz did you guys have fun that
was a blast I thought it was really fun
I liked the phone call at the end and I
don't know it was cool to see everyone
in like the crowd because this is your
first one so it's cool to see everybody
like be a part of that you could tell
they wanted live event in three years of
the show it was and it I feel like
things happen we we say we're gonna do
things and we're not lying it's just
wait wait out but like it was the people
who came they were so fun and cool and
like there was guys in the front row
like so at one point we had these these
text messages about like ghosting which
we can get into but like there were
these like Super Macho guys in the front
that were like don't call him back like
they are so on the girls side it was
just really cool to see like men one had
a man bun I remember like the front row
being mostly men no we had so many guys
we have boy slugs yeah our male
listeners they're the best I know we
don't give them enough attention I feel
like because every now and then you'll
see a comment that's like I'm a random
boy slug I love this am I the only one
yeah no you're not but don't you feel
like on the road our whole audience is
like this always it's like so crazy
they're so good I I don't have like a
meet and greet all the time on the road
I feel like my audiences are a lot it's
a it's usually like short brunettes
mostly like literally all no but like
you know and this was a much more this
was a different kind of crowd like it
was awesome and there was a lot of
couples wait can we talk with a couple
wait okay at the VIP meet and greet the
Maryland couple
know them too we need to talk about them
is that so there is this couple who he
was like yeah you know I saw he was with
his girlfriend and he's like well how I
met her is I saw she posted one of these
clips of kalila saying she just wanted
to gum a dick and I was like I need to
hit up that girl
I was like I want to talk to her and
there they were there was that the swap
me a couple was that the same couple no
no it's what I thought was so funny is
so there's this couple in the front
we're like how did you guys meet and
they're like this is so hacky we met
like selling vintage t-shirts out of
swap meet I was like that's hack he's
like oh we're from Portland I was like
oh okay everyone does that there we're
like that's the cutest job we've ever
heard of but my favorite then too was
the couple that were like
so we're x's and we're in a
situationship and immediately I'm like
what is this like I got so frustrated by
their story but then it was so
interesting they so related to kalila
and Bobby and they just wanted to talk
to you about it and I thought that was
so cool yeah you'd be surprised I think
that you know the general idea is when
you break up with somebody that you're
just supposed to just poof separate but
there are so many people out there that
are still very much like Tethered to one
another because the friendship was real
like and so long too like you guys were
together for so long and so was that
couple in the audience like if you're
with someone for a year maybe I don't
think it's that hard to separate your
life it's like but if your whole like
adult life has been with someone
obviously it's gonna be like a different
situation yeah and it was so cute
because they took pictures with us
separately not as a couple yeah to get
their own you knew like they had other
plans yeah
foreign
[Music]
this show is sponsored by betterhelp let
therapy be your map with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
help.com trash Tuesday take the first
step to visibly thicker healthier hair
for a limited time neutrophil is
offering our listeners ten dollars off
your first month's subscription and free
shipping when you go to neutrifold.com
and enter promo code trash find out why
over 4 000 Healthcare professionals
recommend neutriful for healthier hair
neutrifold.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
that's neutriful.com promo code trash
hey sluggies I am on the road as always
and forever I love meeting you guys I
love seeing you guys you can see me next
on the 27th at The Great Outdoors Comedy
Festival in Calgary with Andrew Schultz
I'll be in San Francisco September 15th
and 16th Austin October 6th and 7th La
Jolla October 13th and 14th San Jose a
Houston and many other places go to
annieleterman.com shows and uh Annie
wood and friends at The Comedy Store the
date will be posted so check my
Instagram
um I don't know the exact date yet but
you will see it September something hi
slugs in a few weeks you can see me
September 14th through 16th at Madison
Wisconsin at the comedy club on State
and then I'll be in DC Boston Chicago
San Diego Detroit and more and you can
get tickets at estheronice.com
[Music]
yes you're so tired is this from uh
Taylor Swift
all day
I like if she's if this is how I feel
from her three-hour concert
there's like vitamin V shot or vitamin B
shots vitamin B
there's things happening backstage
vitamin V they're like so funny
it sounds like a vampire name no it
sounds like it has something to do with
a bite and a vagina yeah vitamin vitamin
the vitamin vitamin B
um it works so fun like you are with
Nikki Glaser yes which like was you to
go it's like the Superman yeah it was
her ninth time she knew everything about
the concert what were you guys wearing
she was wearing a gorgeous pink sparkly
dress I was in a black T-shirt and
Adidas track pants no I can imagine she
got like hair and makeup for this event
this is like her she's like gorgeous I
don't know if she got it pro okay but
um
I went for Comfort obviously I went for
Sporty Spice Comfort Vibes um at one
point and I'll send you a picture to put
up on the episode these little girls
started trading bracelets like over like
lit like they were here and they were
trading with the girl behind me and it
was like I did not exist like I've never
felt more invisible they were just like
doing this all I'm sure you felt that
invisible High School
when people were asking girls to prom
ISE girly Vibes
um was Nikki and heels
I don't think so no I think Nikki was in
yeah I think you want to be comfortable
like she knew all the transitions she
knew like when was a good time to go pee
okay she's like Joe Rogan for the UFC
yeah did you have to sit on her
shoulders at all no the seating is very
great at sofa also you're going tonight
Sofi stadium is what you're going
tonight yeah
I am not I have such heiress tour fomo
it's like unreal I've been playing I
played around the way here on the way
back every single ride home has been
um
t-swift and I have like a lot of regret
it's not too late there's like two
months there's three more I think
Tuesday Wednesday this little girl's
crazy I could do it though yeah I relate
to what she's doing because you you're
like no I should take time off and
they're like but I don't want to you
know I don't want to I actually think
it's very dangerous for you to see this
like I feel like you're gonna go into a
Mania because you know I'm going I'm
going I'm not going necessarily even
though I I do like Taylor Swift I'm
going more for like one it's an iconic
moment it's a historian yes but also
after seeing I went and saw you know
Nickelback I've seen Nickelback I've
seen I'm seeing I love one episode where
we don't bring up Nickelback
Papa Roach is what we should talk about
nothing straight and there will be a
Creed moment and it just hasn't happened
yet but
um but watching I go and I watch like as
a performer yeah obviously they're doing
a completely different thing at a
completely different level but I'm
always like what can I incorporate what
can I learn from these little digit
numbers exactly remember Kobe just
giving yeah so much credit to Taylor and
being like of course I'm gonna study a
person like that her output the length
of time that she's been able to just top
herself with each album that's
incredible like that that takes
discipline and a whole lot of freaking
Talent everyone everyone must respect
her it's a it's a law now but like
before sh before she came out I looked
at Nikki and I was like let's set our
intentions like how do we want to be
different from before and after we see
this even though Nikki's seen it nine
times but and we were kind of like sort
of what you're saying like I want to be
more confident on stage and she
definitely I'm telling you you're gonna
go into a manic episode after you see
her perform at the sofa Stadium like you
are I'm like nervous like I I feel like
somehow you will sell out the sofa
Stadium like by Thursday yeah I like
that that's the goal like it's scary
what this will do to you
because there's just moments where she's
like getting cheers from the crowd and
like taking it in and you re it's so
honest too like you can tell it's not
manufactured like you know when you've
seen maybe other pop stars but she
really was oh
you got a vendetta with someone no I
mean we look we all know that you know
we saw Brittany in Vegas a few times and
it just didn't feel right it didn't sit
right well we knew there was like a
father of well now we know that you know
what that was not fair but it also I
will say I had a deep sadness at the
arrows tour where I was like I wish we
could get this from Brittany and I know
we never most likely will not ever
please well we won't get those weird
cake videos from Taylor so
but like just some like a concert where
Brittany play like yeah baby one more
time oops they did it again era a Slave
for You error do you think obviously
there's like mental illness and and
abuse and stuff involved but with with
Taylor Swift you can see like she she's
like in charge of her career she's so
with it and
greatest most empowering thing about her
it's so weird like I was listening to
some of her songs just to kind of like
refresh and get ready and it's like she
does make you remember like what it
feels like to have like a teen crush oh
my God it's like oh my God yesterday all
day yesterday I cried to the song August
like just in bed because I'm on my
period yeah and I hadn't heard that song
in a little bit and I woke up in the
morning and I was like why why is this
song like in my head it was just like in
a loop in my head and I played it and I
had just a big emo cry yeah it was so
cathartic but it's like that younger
everything every era of her life there's
a song that like speaks to you totally I
hadn't realized how much two that I
actually really do love the lover era
there's so many good songs from that and
that's what she opens with so I feel
like that the the you know the first era
is so much fun I peeked the set list so
I do kind of know what's coming okay
yeah kind of get prepared I will say I
think we have a messed up obviously we
have to go with Nikki but that's the top
experience but I think we should try to
go to Beyonce together I would love that
I so I saw her at Coachella and when I
say that I was exhausted
within the first hour I went from post
Malone and then to Beyonce and I had to
sit down like so many different times
and she was not stopping she just went
on for like the fact that Blue Ivy's on
tour with her is like that's the thing
now she's [__] incredible she's
really good he's incredible I'm also
desperate to see sizza you know what I'm
seeing Oh sza wait she's on tour yeah
she's she's like doing a whole another
run because her first one did so well
I'd be down for that this Sunday I'm
gonna go see
um Maggie Rogers do you know oh okay
yeah she's my favorite song
um Hollywood Bowl okay yeah he's my most
favorite who are you going with
um Jules my sister and my friend Meg oh
cute I have a Taylor Swift story that's
not it's not quite as good so my
sister-in-law my older brother's wife
Ginger is from Wyomissing Pennsylvania
which is where she's from oh Taylor
group and they went to the same church
and her family was trying to get Ginger
to babysit for her and Ginger's like I'm
not babysitting and so she almost was
Taylor Swift's babysitter but she was
like
babysitting this girl no and she could
have been Taylor Swift's babysitter oh
wow
what song she wrote about uh
he's a babysitter song Somewhere in
there yeah well and then also Nikki told
me well there's a song called Enchanted
which I'm sure all the super fans know
this I didn't do you know this yeah wait
no I know the song okay so that song
it's about like meeting a guy in one
night and it's really pretty like you'll
love it it's meeting a guy in one night
and how Enchanted You Are by him and the
lyrics are like I hope you don't love
someone else already you know and
apparently she wrote that about this guy
maybe the band is called like Owl City
is that something you know
she met him at an awards show one night
and I guess like he found out that it
was about him and like ever since then
he's like been writing music about her
like writing her notes and she just like
hasn't responded like I got what I
needed yeah because she just crushed on
him from afar or like had a like a uh
basically had like one night flirtatious
interaction and writes a song and I was
broken she could stretch a real tiny
flirt a little wink across the room and
she got a new album I know it's like if
you're if you're her accountant like you
better call back like on time or that's
a song she like I literally was driving
over here remembering being on the boys
baseball team Little League team like
having a crush on other like I mean
she's like digging up and also I think
being engaged I'm like remembering all
my little like oh I'm going through my
like um
what was the the movie with uh what's
his name where he worked at the record
store and he went back to all of his
exes oh um
but it's him with uh with John Cusack I
know they just Zoe just remade it it's
but but not like oh what the hell why oh
my God
hi Fidelity High Fidelity I'm having my
like High Fidelity moment where like
you're going back and remembering all of
your love I love that wait a second not
in like a disrespectful way to Todd or
anything but like but you know like Zoe
Kravitz um version of High Fidelity is
actually pretty good I liked it I have
not seen it I love I used to always love
that because I was such a girl that like
yearned from my exes for so long up
until like you know but it's not a
terrible thing to you know walk down
memory lane I think that you remind
yourself of like the lessons that you've
learned along the way the things you
wouldn't do again and honestly how far
you've come yeah but his whole thing was
like he was having trouble I think with
his current girlfriend and then he went
back and like visited all his exes to be
like what did I do wrong like what's
wrong with me or what I think it's
healthy yeah yeah maybe yeah I don't I
also like believe in letting people live
their lives like that's always like we
have to believe my ex's name and I'm
like why I'm dragging back into the show
they can live their lives they can they
can block you okay they can live their
lives they can shut the blinds yeah they
have to they're like the deadbolt I do
appreciate though like an X coming back
around a couple years after like making
amends oh but sometimes making amends I
mean they do always come back though you
know an [__] I see now that I was
like really shitty to you and like you
know I'm sorry about that and I like
when people like grow up and take
accountability I had one guy though that
did that to me where he was like he came
back and he's like oh I did like this
Chinese medicine and I did all the
spiritual stuff and I realized like how
much I like hurt you or whatever and I
was like I was not in love with you and
I was afraid I was gonna have an STD
allergic to condoms like I didn't love
you it was like such good Revenge just
to see his face I was like what a
narcissist like you went to go see a
Healer to deal with it what you did to
me oh my God this room I was like are
you kidding me and then he tried to make
out again we made out for a second we
had Invisalign and I'll disrespect I
made out of their retainer
foreign
this show is sponsored by better help
you know if you're thinking of starting
therapy
you should give better help a try
because I have mental health problems
and so do you and so do you and so does
everyone and having someone to talk to
about it to make sure you're not just
going in circles spiraling someone to
help you guide your thoughts someone to
help you figure out what your anxiety
what's the root cause of it you know I
think all these things like everything
we're dealing with today is so stressful
you know I could list a lot of things I
don't need to trigger anybody but like a
therapist can actually help you and look
we're spinning around in our heads
enough do we need to spin around a
parking lot trying to find a spot
go on your computer better help is
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge they
have a great Journal feature where you
can write down your thoughts in between
your sessions let therapy be your map
with better help visit betterhelp dot
com slash trash Tuesday today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
help.com slash trash Tuesday did you
guys know that hair thinning will happen
to approximately one in two women and if
you're among them you're not alone
thinning is normal and neutrophil helps
women address it from within with
science-backed supplements neutrophil is
the number one dermatologist recommended
hair growth supplement clinically shown
to improve visible thickness and
strength from postpartum to menopause to
plant-based Lifestyles and no matter
what stage of life you're in neutrophil
has four unique formulas to support
women each is physician formulated using
drug-free science-backed ingredients so
you get the most reliable results and in
a clinical study 86 percent of women
reported improved hair growth after
taking neutral women's hair growth
supplements for six months and look like
the reason I love neutrophil because it
doesn't promise an overnight fix take
the first step to visibly thicker
healthier hair for a limited time Future
Falls offering our listeners ten dollars
off your first month subscription and
free shipping when you go to
neutriful.com and enter the promo code
trash find out why over four thousand
Healthcare professionals recommend
neutrophil for healthier hair
neutrifold.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
that's nutrifold.com promo code trash
foreign
oh my God this reminds me so when I was
um I must have been like just 20 years
old and I got into this long distance
relationship with a guy who was
stationed in I don't know like the
Middle East somewhere right but he was
maybe like 13 years older than me
and we had this whole like when he had
his RNR he would come visit me for a
couple days and I was like super like
into him right but that lasted very
short like after I was 20 and maybe I
liked him for about four months and then
poof it went away yeah especially when
there's all these things involved that
make it like kind of but for the past 15
years we've just been acquaintances
nothing really happening between us but
when his it's a matter of [__] up man
when his his wife was pregnant
um this was not that long ago it was
about a year and a half ago I think he
was coming off a bad shift from work I
get a random call from this person and
I'm
last night
really whoa x no it was my friend oh I
was like sorry I forgot Angela I didn't
save your number my new phone my bad and
and and so I I pick up because I'm like
oh my God this is an emergency like did
something happen and I pick up and he
was like you know I just want to say
like I'm so sorry for the way I was with
you you were really young and I know
making it seem like there he had such a
he's like jerking off he's like you were
here yeah yeah there's like a heaviness
to his breathing I'm like you know I'm
you know I have a baby on the blah blah
blah blah and in my head I was just like
who are you like like I if you hadn't
called I wouldn't maybe have barely
remembered it's so narcissistic it's
like you did not have an impact in my
life did you just spend the last 15
years thinking that you crushed my soul
or that you that I had been thinking
about you in a way bigger way than I
actually was like it's so self-centered
I'm like I don't you're not even been
the top 20 yeah of boys that I've Loved
it's so weird yeah I kept in touch with
um with a guy from my like Middle School
like I used to go to these Quaker youth
Retreats and I went to this like big I
might have told the story before I went
to this big quicker YouTube called
youthquake where they like brought all
the pictures from all over and we like
stayed in these dorms in like North
Carolina somewhere that sounds so like
calamitous it was I don't know what that
word oh Kalam okay yeah no no I
understand what it means yeah it reminds
me of the brownie earthquake Oreo Sunday
from Dairy Queen oh it does sound better
times it does sound like a Dairy Queen
you need to be able to enjoy
you need to be able to eat and be skinny
um but but so me and a friend of mine
like were we met these boys and I just
got my nipple pierced I just remember
like little things I was 14. so we
climbed out the wind they we said we
were gonna sneak out to hang out with
these boys and the the counselors like
heard us so they parked outside of our
they stayed up all night outside of our
door so we literally tied sheets
together it was snowing and we climbed
out and we scaled the wall and snuck
into the boys room it was so epic it was
so epic you had too much fun when you
were young I it's never stopped I've
never I mean there was a couple
molestations but that's pretty exciting
God that's still like going to court
when you're a kid
I'm like in a Murphy Brown outfit I'm
like
um but I've never been bored ever you
even got like a court episode that's so
cool but so um never been bored so
my friend this kid they all have weird
names that's why I'm like I can't say
they're it's like literally the most
unique weird names but so we like made
out and I like showed him my nipple
rings and that was it you know and then
we stayed friends and I would go visit
him he lived in upstate Pennsylvania so
we would go like snowmobiling and I used
to hang out with him and he's like hick
friends and stuff and um but we kind of
stayed in touch and then he came back
into my life randomly and was like
hitting me up like right after our
breakup in like 2017 or something and I
was like okay you know so we started
talking again
and he lived in Vermont his family lived
in Vermont he's like let's go to Vermont
over
spring or over winter break and I was
like okay
so we go to Vermont and he's like trying
to hook up with me and I'm like I don't
know like in my 30s now I'm like I don't
know
and I was like we've been friends for 20
years like do we even need to like do
this and he goes
yeah but I look at it this way we've
been friends this long so either like
it'll be good or like we don't need to
talk to each other ever again or
something and I was like I don't know
why that worked I was like okay so then
we like hooked up a couple times and I
just I felt like I betrayed this memory
of myself like I got talked into it not
in a way he didn't like assault me in
any way but like I like got convinced of
this thing and I do think it kind of
ruined what was cute about us having
stayed friends was just like Ugh now
we're just grown-ups like it just was
like
I was like kind of grossed out by it not
like a just
just the sort of spoiling of this sort
of like fun childhood memory and then
um he started like writing me love
letters and stuff and I was like no
oh no the Betrayal the Betrayal of it
all but I wish him well and I'll never
talk to him again I got like a text from
my ex-boyfriend I have I pay for White
Pages
so I can like reverse look things up I
pay 4.99 a month that's awesome yeah so
if you ever need a number looked up oh
yeah I'm coming to you there was this um
boy same thing happened to me but in a
little bit of a different way like I had
this memory of just crushing him
crushing on him so hard in high school
and really never getting his attention
and then one one time after like two
years after graduation I hooked up with
him and it was like sort of this perfect
ending to this like long-standing Crush
I had with this boy right but then not
too long ago like three years ago I got
this Facebook message and I see his name
and I'm like oh my God like my heart
skipped a beat a little bit because I'm
like I haven't really seen him heard
from him since I don't know we were like
1918 or whatever
and the message basically said that he
needed money because he had a bad dude
a bad tooth is so nasty yeah and I share
that with you I know and so what I ended
up doing was that I had my friend who's
like a pharmacist in New York like write
him a script for
um you know on antibiotics but I was
like I'm not gonna [__] send you
money and it just shattered that memory
I had that sweet sweet memory of like I
crushed your crush it crushed my crew we
crushed so many of our crushes that's
what someone on Tick Tock said they're
like a crush is just when you don't have
information yet that really is right
it's just a crush it's just I love about
all your information gets wild but that
is so true no crushes on tick tock
and it's so dangerous to have a crush
because like the first couple times
you're just seeing everything through
like rose-colored glasses they can do no
wrong well don't remember having like a
bigger crush on a guy like at night and
then during the day but like you
couldn't like make moves at night like I
couldn't be like yes I'm gonna be your
girlfriend at night because then in the
morning I'd be like
I've gone back Taylor Swift has gone
look guys I'm talking like Crush Warrior
don't even masturbate yet like that type
of crush where you're like do you have a
crush or did you have a crush that today
you still kind of feel like they've all
been ruined like lifelong crushes wait
that's such a good question
I feel like I should but I don't nothing
is coming up which is probably a good
thing well I had like my next door
neighbor forever we made out a couple
Christmases ago I was like all right get
out of here but see you had some type of
he's high I think I'll always think he's
so hot just because he and like other
people might not think he's hot but I
like he was so hot because when I was 11
when he moved to next door to me and it
was like
I mean I was like my mind was blah I
couldn't believe it I was like you know
wearing like necklaces I made at camp
you know but I think maybe that's your
lifelong Crush then if they're still
kind of like oh he's I'm still friends
with him I I find him to be difficult
though
you don't you do yeah I feel like I have
like guys who I was friends with in high
school and stuff who I just had so much
fun with that I was like I wonder if
when I'm older or something but I never
felt it but I almost like wanted to feel
it because I like had so much fun with
them I had or people even from
elementary school like guys where I just
again like had so much fun with them but
it was never more than that and that is
almost there's almost something like
like sad like you want it to go further
but it's
yeah just like it's it's not really yeah
I don't know it's so funny for us to be
like fully engaged talking about these
things I don't think I think it's so
healthy and normal yeah it's normal like
I think it should live in a world where
we're pretending that other women aren't
hot to our guys or like porn is not
they're not allowed or we're not allowed
to think about our exes or whatever like
I just I hate the falseness of that we
who is your crush it's his this boy who
I had such a huge crush on in high
school and I haven't been able to get
over him or I mean like not I'm over him
but if I see him like on Instagram or
whatever if he replies to my stories I'm
still like sooning his name is John I'll
leave it at that but he's this really
really hot Taiwanese guy and I ever if I
hear this one stained song remember the
Bandstand of course I mean remember we
listen to them all the time
um
there's this one song called it's been a
while yeah duh yeah even I know that
yeah and so when I one like at least
once a year I'll play that song and I'll
think of him and it lives inside my body
still my crush lives inside like to me I
hear that and I'm like that sounds so
much fun like you are having so much fun
when you get to see that his picture
have that feeling listen to that song
like that's like play time to me there's
like you could fully be in a
relationship with someone else and still
do that and I think that's so like cute
and a fun healthy thing for you he like
we will never be together I can 150 sure
that we will never like we just it's
just but that fantasy is so much better
than anyway as someone that has
literally had sex with everyone that I
ever like I went back and I banged
everyone
yes and it was so sad
it was so sad
it was so I kind of okay I banged my
like main love love okay my main love
love and he brought me into his after we
banged he's like let's look at old
pictures of us and he just pulled up
pictures of me when I was 20 and was
like look how hot you were I like wanted
to die I was like what the [__] is this
oh my God that's [__] up I was like
well you were [__] ugly sorry I've
been molested so I was a little low
um so I initially had thought that I was
gonna have
I initially thought that I was gonna
have a rat girl summer and I don't know
if you guys know what a rap girl summer
but it's basically I'm gonna eat
everything
um [__] everything basically just having
like a free girl summer right but now I
raise four turtles in the right on the
sewer to be ninjas ninjas
um but then now I'm thinking what I want
to do is I want to do some emotional
edging and I want to crush on someone so
bad but just like not do anything about
it and just like let it like just eat me
up
do you feel like okay as someone in a
full-blown serious relationship do you
feel like a crush helps you in the in
the bedroom you just crush and banger
I've never been that person like I've
never
I've never like thought of another
person or like even you know when you're
jerking it like I never it's like for me
it's like kind of porn like that's kind
of it I've never had that experience
like a distance thing where it's like
not people that are like yeah are you
just watching you are watching and
you're
you're like in a window like
when you're watching porn
um and let's say I'm assuming it's like
two girls say for instance whatever it
is I don't know are you looking at her
Express what makes you I don't know and
I don't like this question it's not fair
this this conversation oh because I had
to figure out what I would make and it
turns out it's not looking at the [__]
it's looking at the reaction
I figured this out yesterday were we
just talking about emotional edging like
let's go back to that please yes but
what are what uh you know what I mean
Revelation for myself
that I'm actually kind of PG I don't
need the hardcore stuff I think I just
need the expression yeah I think that
makes sense I I think the idea of
emotional edging is like really cute and
fun I almost feel like we can do this in
a relationship like
I don't know it's like cheating though
no when you travel away from them and
then like think about them I don't know
I'm just thinking like building up some
sort of we do have a good we do have a
good job for like staying crushing on
our loved ones yeah when I I was just
out of town for two weeks in New York
and I was like obsessed with Dave yeah I
was gone like so much I was just
thinking about him I'm like I miss him
longing for him I'm still like that when
he goes to like the reptile store I'm
like
like if I come home and Todd's not home
like they're the Earth shakes I'm like
where the [__] is Todd oh but when you
guys are back together that first
meeting again is it does it match the
feeling you have when you're away from
each other it always depends what'd you
say she'll be like oh
right because like when Bobby was like
taller yeah like we were just like such
lovers on the phone I miss you I can't
live without you you're the best thing
that's ever like so sweet but then he
comes home and he drops his suitcase
what's up and there's nothing you know
it is weird no I have that exact thing
where like when we're away and like oh
I'm dreaming of my dream man like after
10 years together like it's yeah so I
think that is a version of emotional
edging just like when you're traveling
away from each other yeah I think it's
important for relationships to breathe
physically to like away from each other
yeah
yeah and he's also be
sewn together
um yeah no Todd picks me up from the
airport every time so cute and Randy is
on time
um if he's
wants to have a good day
no well it's always like
I'm always like out there waiting for
like three to ten minutes probably
do you know what I mean we live so close
to the airport that I call him when like
the plane lands so it's like usually he
gets there like a couple like maybe I
can't believe you live close to the
airport that is um and Randy's like it's
so cute the whole thing's so cute I
don't make him get out and put my bag in
the trunk though that's where I feel
like I'm so nice to him does he get does
he try to get out
no
he has road rage so he's pissed he's
like so mad that he's been in airport
traffic
so that I have to sue them yeah that
makes sense Bobby used to have this uh
requirement of me in the early years
that
um apparently I didn't follow through
with very well but he liked to be picked
up at the airport
way yeah no we have very specific under
the armpits
I had to have a coffee in hand like at
the edge at the edge of the elevator on
the elevator at the escalator oh we made
you park you're the monster he made me
party he was like you have to park and
it says LAX you know and he he would
travel like every other weekend yeah no
we're gone I'm not there for it every
day so just to get your coffee so I
would and if I was even a minute late he
would be so upset with me because he
he's like this is my love language this
is how I feel loved and you get it wrong
every time what this is I didn't know
you could act this way if I was like can
I just pick you up curbside not alone
he didn't allow it so you had to meet
him with a coffee at the elevator yeah
and look like with the look of Joy on my
mind back in the day my parents used to
pick me up and like be like I would get
off the plane and they would be there
before 9 11 you could do that oh yeah it
was so cute except one time they were
wearing I came back from Hawaii and my
mom was wearing my dad was wearing like
the dread thing my mom was wearing like
a Dolphin hat I was like uh like in the
Philadelphia Airport I'm like I don't
think white people allowed to wear the
dread hat
[Music]
you guys it's getting juicy brought to
you by simply spiked we are about to get
into gossip corner right here so
definitely stick around for this
um okay I asked our listeners for some
juicy gossip let's see what we have so
someone sent in here's some tea my
boyfriend of almost three years got
engaged to a family friend whose name
I've heard before six months after us
breaking up did I break up with him yes
did we talk about marriage ourselves yes
very seriously where were we in
communication about our present feelings
for each other two months before yes did
he give me the heads up about the
engagement no did I find it in my of my
car at a red light on Instagram yes is
this Petty no because I've been so
silent about how absolutely wild this
has been and he listens to this podcast
oh no oh my God and was the one who told
me about this podcast to get through
this and I have since been a loyal
follower so yeah that's right I'm not
saying the name
um but she's just saying that these have
been a crazy past few months
and peace and love to us three well I
think the sometimes people come into
your life just to tell you about trash
Tuesday yeah and sometimes you have to
be with them for 40 years and suffer but
you broke up with him girl so here's the
thing like it you are right to be hurt
yeah but
you have to just move on because you
have to remember you left him you didn't
want to do this with him you discussed
getting married you didn't want to get
married he obviously is like very ready
to get married or feels that he is and
he found someone that's down and you
just have to but I could also see how
maybe she's feeling gaslit like
what if he wasn't that great of a
partner because he already had his toe
dipping in with someone else so she
thinks maybe there was a cheating
situation I don't know overlap it was a
family friend of hers yeah
I do think though you're so right the
best thing always even if you weren't
the one to break up is to always think
back on
why you think it wouldn't have worked
and she has the advantage here that she
did break up with this person so she can
really go to that well of where she was
when she broke up but I still get it's
so shocking but also if it's someone
that they knew before you so you're like
oh but I think if you're if you're in a
Like Loving light Vibe right and you're
going I want what's best for everyone
maybe he did realize he had had these
feelings for this girl and he knows her
well so that's why they could move fast
faster I've already known her a long
time it's a familiar so it's not
necessarily that they were cheating on
each other but that maybe they realized
oh wait there was actually a spark here
that's true like that could definitely
expedite a relationship especially if
you have a history with someone even if
that history is purely platonic or even
completely appropriate I mean that's
happened with me where
um like after with you Bobby I I dated
the Jeweler right oh and you knew him
before but he knew me intimately because
I was telling him why I liked Coral why
certain gemstones meant something to me
though so there was like a communication
because he had to get to know me in
order to figure out like what but then
it was purely platonic and he was so
professional about it and until like
months after when he was like you know
hey how are you kind of deal you know or
he was also the first person who had to
find out that
we were broken up he was he had to hold
that secret before six months before
Bobby and I announced that we were
actually like not together so he was
privy to something so he was privy to
something that no one else knew about
you know and even before you guys so
that creates like really in an intimacy
yeah and I told him it's like you know
it's not working out he's like don't you
know like it's okay I'll be here if it
does like there was already that kind of
feeling of safety again super
professional super platonic so by the
time that we did when we did reconnect
it was more like oh I feel like I kind
of like trust this person already and no
I see it moved really fast right
um so I can kind of understand how what
Annie is saying how like just knowing
who they are just speeds it up but and
the thing is he doesn't know you already
you've told him I am not your person so
for him it's healthy for him to move on
correct that's so true but Counterpoint
is
anytime people are moving really fast
I'm like
red black
yes that's all yes pedal to the metal is
very scary quick burnout she can at
least feel that security of like okay if
he's moving fast that's not necessarily
like something healthy that's going on
there I could be wrong
but I think what you're saying too is
hitting it on the head it's like she did
end it he should be free to fly and even
though it burns right it hurts and he
doesn't have to give you the heads up
because I had this happen too where I
was living with this guy for three years
I broke up with him he I moved to New
York for a little bit just to like kind
of let things cool off he did not move
out of my apartment and ended up kind of
just like I just had to like forfeit the
apartment to him because he was such a
loser he couldn't afford a
anything else it was so annoying like it
was still my apartment it was very very
annoying but rather than deal with the
stress of it and I think I felt guilty
because I broke his heart or whatever I
end up just like forfeiting this
this apartment to him that he's
squatting in
um I stopped paying for it and then I
find out when I come back into town to
get on my stuff he like won't let me in
the apartment to see the cats or
anything or go into my apartment
and um it's because he has a girl a new
girlfriend and that pissed me off that
he didn't tell me and like my stuff is
still there and it was he did steal my
apartment so there were all these things
and I was annoyed about it but he
doesn't have to tell me that like he
wasn't wrong in it it was annoying for
me and I think some of it that gets
annoying is like you have these guys
that are like I would die without you
you know like and then they're not
that's just how they felt in the moment
so then your ego takes like this hit of
like oh okay you were very easily able
to move on you are bringing up such a
good point like do would we want our ex
to alert us hey I found someone or Would
we not it's just not my business like it
really isn't and he wasn't a guy that
was like trying to be my friend or
anything past it
but now I'm torn because I'm like there
is something kind of polite about like
getting the heads up
I mean if this person might be in my
home when I'm coming to get my stuff but
she also attacked me online and like
went crazy oof yeah so that's where I
was like you didn't tell me you're
getting a mentally ill person that's
like gonna make it sounds like sounds
like things were really great for them
but you know what guys I'm
but he still didn't have to tell me
um I think that while I don't require it
and I you know once we're broken up like
you really are free to do whatever you
want in your own timeline like if my ego
stings my ego is yeah it stings but
that's on me right to solve myself but
um a heads up would actually be really
polite I would I would
that would be especially if things ended
like amicably or if that person knows
that it might like hurt me or put me in
some weird space
um I would be like hey just wanted to
let you know that like I met someone
like thank you like our time was very
meaningful yeah yeah it's respectful to
you but it's actually disrespectful as a
person I think it is disrespectful to
the new girl I think it is really yes
because
because I have I have untied the knot
okay I have said to you
I you are not my person this is not for
us we are not going to get married and
then
I'm saying to that person like you're
cut free yeah I'm not like for me to go
let's still maintain this thing I want
you to still prioritize my feelings like
I think the issue is that he hit her up
two months in and was like we still have
feelings for each other I see the fact
that he was still dabbling with that
that
but are messed up but I do think that
like when you break up with someone you
have they are gone right they are not
you cannot half break up with someone
and I don't think that I think it's
actually inappropriate to like hold your
feelings I think you're right about
higher than the girls but I think that
that is so different from a friendly
like
hey like hope you're well I just want to
give you this I just want to let you
know I think there is a difference there
but if he's to the point where he's
going to marry someone else he shouldn't
even be considering her feelings
shouldn't be becoming he should be
focused on his new one new relationship
I don't see what would be so bad about
Bobby goes off and falls in love and he
tells kalila like yeah but they work
together they see we're still very
enmeshed in a lot they are still a
meshed yeah like we still are and a girl
that would be dating Bobby now would
know that right so um yeah between Bobby
and I like if I meet someone and it's
about to get serious like he would have
to absolutely know
um because he's still very much a part
of my life so it's a very but that's
that's an unusual circumstance what him
and I have but you know I I started
dating a guy recently and I basically
told him like Hey I still have residual
feelings for someone else and what his
response to that was really cool he was
like you know like obviously he's my
direct competition so it doesn't make me
feel great but like I would love it if
you could practice some discipline and
like cut that off while like you're
saying and I'm like oh my God he used
the word discipline and I was like oh
you're right because that's always just
been like a comfortable thing for me to
always like make me nails that's hot
but really like calm and cool and chill
about it and not like like applying too
much pressure but I'm like oh you're
right but you're calling out my lack of
discipline you are absolutely correct
what I will say though about like
to put a button on all of this because
that is actually so hot
um
to our our slug is I would say like my
mama slug advice is like this is just
your ego it's all good and like you've
been given a gift to be able to get over
this faster and not ruminate over what
ifs and stuff and you're just
like you like
just cut yourself off like thank God
this won't be a getting back together
right you know thank God it's clean so
at least there's that yep you guys it's
been an extremely wouldn't you say kind
of an inferno of a summer it's so hot
out it's so muggy after you walked out
of your car today I almost passed out I
didn't almost didn't make it and it was
three steps to the door it was two steps
and I carried over the threshold like it
was our honeymoon
um this has been one of the most
refreshing drinks I've drank this summer
I take it to all of my social Gatherings
my family parties it is so good you guys
it's a simply spiked this particular
one's a kiwi Peach but they have a mango
they have the um just a regular Peach
one it genuinely it tastes just like
fruit juice they have signature Peach
strawberry peach kiwi Peach and mango
peach which all sounds so refreshing and
summery and fun but it's so good real
fruit juice
um 21 and up only contains alcohol go to
drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday to
find out how to get your hands on simply
spikes lemonade and simply spiked Peach
that's drinksimplyspike.com trash
Tuesday flavored beer naturally flavored
with other natural flavors simply spiked
call Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply so I can simply Spike
eliminate our trademarks with a Simply
Orange Juice company
one time post 911 and also when I was
over 18 my dad was like she's a child
and they didn't check and they just let
them come in with me I was like wow did
you ever do the on
no I didn't travel as a minor you did
what was it like I always thought that
was so cool it was kind of annoying
because I already smoked cigarettes so I
was like people are just cramping my
cigarette so I was like trying to go
smoke they're just like babysitting me I
was like hello
oh God I just I I had a memory of
traveling without my parents to
Indonesia because I was at a the
Southeast Asian Games because I was
representing my country at the age of
12. and but my parents couldn't come my
sister wasn't there and I was staying at
some like I was in Jakarta Indonesia and
I wanted to call my Mom this is before
cell phones and they were like here's a
calling card I'd never used a calling
card before I didn't know that you had
to like punch in the number of the
calling card and so they're like please
enter your calling card number and I'd
like seven eight and I couldn't get a
hold of her for like two days and I was
having like a nervous breakdown in
Indonesia by myself oh my she was really
freaking out too like is my daughter
dead yeah but then she saw me on TV so
oh she made it but I was also I had a
really bad ear infection I had a fever I
swear I'm the worst race in my life I
basically shamed my country like I think
I finished all at 12 at 12 I finished
like eighth or something
I know that's bad yeah yeah I was fourth
is like you're getting a beating I swam
with it there's like nobody's even
beating you they're like but then I was
competing against like full grown adults
like I was the youngest no but I but
imagine that like
but still there was expectation of me
and I remember finishing eighth and like
having like my tail tucked between my
legs and being like Oh like I am like my
country is gonna shut oh my God and then
not because of the tail this is so
traumatizing what you're telling me
you're in a foreign country you felt the
weight of your own home country on your
shoulders and you couldn't get into the
broad broad swimmer shoulders like I
said I would not survive that at age 35
like that is so terrifying yeah the
swimming part
it's even what makes it even sadder is
that there's a picture of me in the
newspaper at the airport so on my way to
and on my way to Indonesia clutching
um a stuffed turtle like that's how
young I was in my head like I looked
really sick and pale because I had a
fever and I was clutching a stuffed
animal like this they sent that girl to
compete
and she did not do well this is why
that's why Pepsi [__] you guys over
Pepsi retaliated
this is why Bobby expected perfect
airport pickups he knew you've been
through some [__] and you can handle it
right you're right yeah my threshold for
for abuse is high suffering yeah wow
that it really is a thing huh did he
want to sign
he you know what he probably did I
remember I love a sign do you like when
there's a sign
I love it I love a sign but to be fair
when he needed to pick me up from the
airport he really went like above and
beyond really he was really great he's
never been late to pick me up at the
airport so maybe that's just his his
love language his love language what
always happens is Todd will get there
he'll be like yeah I'm in traffic and I
go okay do you want me to like walk
closer to he's like no just stay there
I'm like okay are you sure because I
could just walk because I don't I'd
rather walk than sit stand
the airport pickup process has
definitely gotten us into some pretty
big fights like where yes it's just a
very tense LAX Airport pickups like a
couple that can survive that is a really
strong well the non-stop construction
for the past 47 years with no
improvements there's no improvements
it's just gets the lane gets skinnier
and skinnier
it's so weird there's always like the
cop yelling at you to the movie like why
are you there
what is going on go do go direct traffic
like I long for a small town lifestyle
just so that I could have like a small
airport where that watches you yeah
you're the biggest one there this is why
I um fly out of Long Beach a lot because
you do three gates yeah if I go to
Hawaii I go Long Beach I would rather
drive the extra 15 minutes because
burbank's Q2 but it doesn't go to Hawaii
no not direct but there's so many
flights out of Long Beach Street to
Hawaii and it's just it's not even that
far for you yeah wait really how how far
is it
um you just drive an extra 15 minutes
from LAX to get to the Long Beach
Airport there's like three gates it's
the easiest thing it's so fast it's
better than Burbank oh my God if they I
doubt they go to Chicago but if they did
like that will be my new home
but Long Beach is so far from you yeah
but that would actually be worth it
because the experience there yeah it's
less time and also a lot of good
restaurants in Long Beach let's suppose
you pick up a friend from the airport
there we always just eat around the area
are you just like priming us to pick you
up at the Long Beach Airport I live
there for so long I love it there in
Long Beach Long Beach is the best
we need that we need a full Long Beach
exploration day that would be a good
place for a live show yeah they Laugh
Factory there where else at the
convention center
we're taking over The Long Beach Laugh
Factory you guys ready to be a factory
full of laughs come see us there we I
have a really cool I know you're gonna
make fun of me for how boring this is
but it's like a very normal life person
question I'm like so scared to ask it
it's so bad
when you are at the grocery store and
you're buying cheese
like do you have a preference do you
taste it first do you have a preference
between if you're buying cheddar like
mild medium or Sharp
what is it I you know I rarely buy
cheddar I if I want some cheddar I'll
probably go for like a colby jack
um or some type but cheddar is not my
jam
okay but I will not I'll usually go
sharp me too and I don't know why that's
always what I go for and I notice that's
the one that's like always the most sold
out and I'm like does anyone like miles
I'm unable to
participate do you grocery shop yeah
yeah but I just get like I don't get a
lot of things but I'm not a cheese
person but also I can't
yeah I'm not in the cheese I feel almost
like a personal attack on because you oh
because you're wearing that question I
mean it's just so I have enough I know
but you know what is good you are
tapping into like a a normie like I know
that the comments will be about this I
hope they are I want to know who's
buying mild and medium and should I try
it and then also I have a question so
I've been like at home I've been
remaking different like Chick-fil-A
sauces and dressings okay
do you guys have a favorite Chick-fil-A
sauce I like the Chick-fil-A sauce okay
that's kind of the right answer yeah but
I like I do kind of like all of them
Polynesian they are all good I do like
every single one like can I have one of
each I always that's where all of them I
do too oh but like can you guys pour all
of them in one cup into my mouth
buy the real bottle of the Chick-fil-A
sauces the full size I've bought that
too but I feel like
you scared of the plastic I'd rather I'd
rather make it myself and it's actually
Chick-fil-A sauce like I'm pretty sure
it's just barbecue sauce mustard and
mayo it might be one other thing but
it's on Pinterest like it's easy to
recreate
so I guess I'm just putting that out
there
wow
I'm riveted just losing my mind here I'm
so excited I can't believe it I just
never thought I'd live in a world where
I could make my own Chick-fil-A sauce so
I'm really I'm not sure you can
I'd like to taste it yeah I'm curious as
well I want to taste it why does it
taste like lemonade
I've also made they have this like apple
cider vinaigrette dressing that is so
good and they've made a version of that
at home so
anyways that's where my life is going
um more Normie stuff have you guys had
the Frenchie girl yogurt from the
Larchmont
um farmer's market no what is that it
will change your life why it's the best
yogurt I have ever had
okay in my life what kind of yogurt is
it they have everything from guava key
lime strawberry they make Suzuki she
makes cream cheeses as well but it is so
good I have to let's have her on
wait what is the orange girl what
Farmers Market is it at Larchmont okay
when I'm out of town however as a guest
I dare you oh my God we're witches can I
tell you why we're witches
last episode
episode before this I think
did we not talk about Jeremy Allen White
yeah we did we did right yeah and how I
he can get it yeah I walked out of my
yoga class yesterday and the first
person I see like with a coffee in his
hand is carmy did you drop to your knees
oh my goodness like I I don't know what
I did but I ran away as fast as I could
obviously yeah
and then but my sister was like
oh my okay so I want to play a scenario
let's say we are together we walk out we
see him do we make moves to set them up
yes do you stop me from talking to him
no no you don't speak as much exactly I
use your credits what am I doing while
this is happening I use your credits
there's a movie coming out
she's a movie coming out she stars and
wrote it wait what am I doing while this
is happening you're not there you're not
there okay you're not there I've ran
away because we've we've found because
we could charm in the weirdest way and
we could actually make it happen yeah
yeah let's play it out
okay let's play it out so what happens
is we see him I go we gotta Esther goes
you go you go I go all right and then
like you go and you say your stuff
you're in my shadow a little bit I'm
like oh my God I'm sorry she's like so
annoying yeah like I'm so sorry even
though Esther's literally been like you
had like it's like good cop bad cop like
we have to like really play the game I'm
too much Esther somehow gets his number
we're like our friend is so we basically
like our friend is like so hot she's
really hot she was abused by the
Philippines as a child
she is Asian she'll be able to wash
clothes off her abs we're gonna washing
clothes
she dated a stand-up comedian for 10
years so she can handle it anything yeah
she can handle it that's a great Point
there's a great thing Andrew Keegan's
trying to get at her on Raya he actually
has not he him leaving it unseen the DM
is wait wait a second I don't think we
talked about this so you dm'd it I saw
my goal because I saw him in Venice and
I was like I don't want to stop I don't
want to bother him he was like with his
kid so I sent him a dime I go oh I just
saw you I'm from Venice
um
I go I have a podcast
um or no I said something like I was
like oh you know his thing full circle
has like maybe it was a call maybe it
wasn't yeah I looked it up I was like I
would have been in this yeah 100 nothing
bad it was there was some hard kombucha
that I wouldn't have been involved with
but yeah but this is before cut
kombucha this is for kombucha blew up so
I think he got a um unfair uh kind of I
mean I would have been I wouldn't have
been drinking alcohol so I would have
been like just the person watching
everyone I guess get drunk off camera
but I was like I'm so sad I came to
Venice too late after full circle is
that what you said on him yeah because
full circles out
because full circle got shut down over
covered it was still going really no
he's still I did a lot of research like
I made sure it's still like a oh okay
it's like a kosher thing it just went
out it just went out of business over
coven
they couldn't sustain so then I go I
have a podcast with
two other girls and I put your names in
it's called trash Tuesday
um
the like something like the you know
the girl who watched
I would I would the girl who watched
um
what's the movie I was talking about
Camp Nowhere over and over again would
kill me if I don't ask you to come on
our podcast oh that's sweet it was like
really cute and then
seen and no response
I hit him on many layers too I have to
say I'm surprised you're not more used
to the experience of an unresponsive to
them mostly responded to because I
that's like such a normal part of my my
culture do you call DM a lot of people
yeah and I like never get responses and
that's just like the name of the game I
just assume I'm always gonna get a
response
and especially if I because I saw him so
I went oh okay this is the time because
I just saw him should hit him up be like
oh I just I was like oh I just saw you
that I don't want to bother you
yeah I did this as some more thing with
this like one of my favorite models I
saw her walking in New York and then the
next day I like dm'd her and was like if
you want to come to my show
nothing
I know we have such a cool thing to
offer though I feel like where it's like
come to The Comedy Store come to a show
did it sting a little I wish you would
have responded but I knew that it's it's
such a long shot it's like people don't
like think about when you get DMS it's
like you just don't know and it's like
too much to really like do your own
research it's just best to have people
come to you but sometimes you try and
it's like we're I think it's worth
putting yourself out there because
that's like what our whole job is but I
think it's I just I'm not like giving up
that I think Andrew could give a crush I
mean his his Instagram is like him and
his daughter so like I don't know if he
thought I was like coming at him that
way maybe if you look at my Instagram
I'm very in a relationship I'm not like
maybe I wasn't trying to maybe I should
be making it seem like I want to bang
have we tried Devon Sawa at all I feel
like we got we can get to Evan said I
haven't tried them yet we can get like
really active on Twitter
so let's try X it's X now X yeah
Eli what are you up to Eli you changed
his name for him Eli I'm changing your
name now
if you change the Twitter I'm changing
your name
I feel like that'd be a good boy name
for you Eli ew why you don't want a boy
name you don't want a boy name
I don't want to be Eli what do you want
to be beside you can't be Jacob because
that's a dog's name
Jake's a great name though Jake Jacob
what would your boy name be
you tell me you call me Adam Adam you
look like I know too many atoms you look
like an Adam you're in my Adam's Apple
you're just a Dead Ringer Adam's apple
you kind of do look like an Adam
it's pretty obvious
Kyle no no Khalil
I saw on Instagram that someone is there
naming their baby after you yeah I get
that a lot you do yeah because it's just
it's a unique name oh I know so it's um
yeah I think that's maybe
since podcasting I've had at least maybe
15. that's like the girl version of a
tattoo like Joe Rogan gets like tattoos
and we get babies named after us well I
went once what a fan and she's like my
dog's name is Esther because I love the
show Alone Together I was like that's
something okay you're doggy well she
could have named it Benji
which would have been more appropriate
yes but it's so strange that was
actually a great dog name that's so cute
I disagree because it's your name yeah
yeah I also don't like person people I
love people names for dogs Dave likes it
too I don't like it but Randy was like
the we were like looking at Randy for
like two weeks before we named him like
this is Randy oh yeah Randy is people
get weird Randy when I meet Randy like
oh my God my dog's name's Randy they're
very upset about him like why would that
upset you
a dog's cuter than you I do you're lucky
to share his name I've never I didn't
live in existence where anyone else was
kalila so I think that kind of [__]
with your head a little bit yeah I feel
almost I have a version of that because
I never meet Esther's because you don't
go to the old folks home enough no I
should volunteer more to get to figure
that out you would actually be so cute
doing your like singing and dancing at
an old folks I would love that I did a
stand-up show I don't know like I ran a
room that was at an old Focus really
yeah it was not great oh I would have
loved to do that you would have been the
only person who would have loved it it
was a really tough crowd it's I love a
tough crowd have you ever did you ever
do the synagogue shows
yes there was this I don't remember who
used to run them but there was a rabbi
who was like also a surfer he's like a
hot like zaddy rabbi
and it would be for his it was for his
place I don't know in La yeah
no the old folks home stand up show I
would say
there's I in my time of doing it there
was never one laugh we got a new
audience each time
it was a tough show I remember Gerard
doing it I feel like he did okay
um yeah and Jamar I think did it you ran
it what was your thought process it was
just like oh the thing to do when you're
like starting out as a comic is to oh
like do a room and I was like everyone's
already done everything I want it to be
something different and like free yeah
and also like have like sports stuff
like
when you start to like your level of
friends that you get to do your show
they will do them in these like weird
places or not people are still
workshopping let's just say that yeah oh
my God you're not getting that many
people with full sets that are like
ready to go
that's would you like to end up in a
retirement home or some type of
old folk song I don't know like what's
your what you haven't thought that far
ahead
do you what do you think we're Asian so
we kind of just like stay with your
family with our family you know like for
better or worse and it's usually worse
and
um but we just stick it out we don't
really send our I want to stay with
family I like family yeah so it's kind
of like dude there was I told you the
story about how my dad like when he was
already in and out of just Lucidity how
he would forget who my sister was and
you know try to call the cops on her and
[__]
because you know and he would try to
throw his like dirty diaper like just
like slap her in the face with it
because but that's what happens I micro
does mushrooms and they're just hitting
this is like the worst conversation
you're on mushrooms yeah they just said
well like how much of them I don't know
I just took one capsule oh my gosh I
didn't read the label
[Laughter]
I have yet to micro dose I really need
to get on this heavy macroed not macro
either
I do feel like I don't want to but I a
good brain rewiring in some way that's
not drug related would be good for me
right now yeah like a sound bath does
that oh yeah you can do breath work you
should do breath work in a sound but
there's no drugs involved where do you
do that I'll find a good one I would do
that as a group activity for sure it's
amazing yeah I love sound baths
I did one once and I it was like the
first time I fell asleep like peacefully
my friend Angela who facetimed me last
night he he was my hookup to all the
good ones I'll find a good one oh I just
remember Joe Mandy's wife does sound
baths oh really yeah
but breath work too would be good yeah I
think the mix is what's up
Todd say something's so funny the other
day
um where so Whitney's baby shower is
like during skank Fest so I'm Gonna
Leave skank Fest and go directly from
skank Fest to Whitney's baby showers
we're gonna be all [__] up Todd's like
we're gonna be like Johnny Depp like
give me the baby like
like from Fear and Loathing when he
stopped tripping
we're gonna be [__] up at that baby
shower
how do we feel about baby showers in
general
well if it's what I love I'm psyched
yeah like Whitney I'm gonna I'm gonna
leave my favorite place skank fast in
Vegas to come to it oh I'm gonna be in
the east coast I'm so sad I'm gonna miss
it yeah well you might get mistaken for
babies it's probably safe for me to stay
back people keep breastfeeding you
though oh you're gonna miss out
um baby showers are like a little
uncomfortable for me and it's I think
because they're not like a regular event
where it's like very casual I've noticed
like you kind of have to participate in
activities it's very much like a group
effort and I feel like if it's not the
right group it can be a little like
intimidating or uncomfortable Whitney's
is going to be wild Wendy's will be fun
no Wendy's does not apply obviously
but
yeah I'm gonna be
tripping balls at her thing still
probably
I go hard it's gang Fest
oh my gosh well you guys thank you so
much for being here and any last
thoughts do you buy a mild medium or
sharp cheddar guys comment below we know
what all you guys want to talk about is
the cheese what's your favorite
Chick-fil-A sauce what's your favorite
Chick-fil-A sauce and do you think
Esther's able to make it to where
well for the next episode will you make
it for us and then we take we do a taste
test potentially oh yeah she's gonna
make us pear that's okay I'm gonna put
the costume on like I work there
um we'll see you guys next week with a
brand new episode and thank you again to
all the Slugs who came out to our live
show so awesome it was so much fun we
had the best time we were laughing all
weekend about it and we can't wait to do
more of those so be on the lookout we'll
see you guys next week
[Music]
oh